hey it's peter rubin with wired as we
know in recent years comic-con has
become a mecca for all things digital
and big budget and just spectacle
overall whether it's peter jackson's
quest to get 48 frames per second in the
hobbit later this year or it's fortnite
from epic games announcing that they're
going to be running on unreal engine 4
when they launch but for me nothing
could really replace the original intent
of the show which is
comics obviously but also tabletop
gaming and all things analog and fantasy
based which is why we're standing here
at the chessex counter
in front of dice because i love dice the
colors the purposes always collected
them there's something
so joyous to me about just being able to
stand and take in the the variation and
the purpose of all these things i mean
these are world creators right here and
let's not lose sight that all we used to
have to do was use our imaginations
people are doing it for us and thank god
for magicians like peter jackson but
we've also got the power ourselves and
let's not forget that stay tuned all
weekend and week long for more comic-con
coverage at wired.com